Why get mad when I call my wife my property? That's right. I
own her. She belongs to me. And has he had warned her
Andrew Wilson, I consent. Rachel Wilson, I consent. Tilly screeching
in THE CORNER, I DON'T.
HE'S A Andrew Wilson's a I saw you did Did you do sit with Andrew
Wilson? That's one thing I would disagree with you. doing, which
is interesting. Like maybe that's the where the debate happens.
>> Yeah. Oh, interesting.
I just worry immediately for your safety in that moment
because of the fact that he's a Andrew Wilson's a I mean, he's
admitted on live streams before on his podcast that he doesn't
really believe in in what he understands the modern version of
consent to look like. I think I may actually have a moral obligation
to pursue legal action against Tilly. Otherwise, I truly believe
she will falsely accuse a man of rape and ruin his life. Do you
think that me rolling over in the morning and she's asleep and
waking you up with just a scrape? >> Well, I mean, she's
unconscious if she had too much to drink and passed out. >> I've
we've done that, too. We were both drunk. Yeah. Well, I mean,
was she passed out?
Hi Andrew. What you're about to witness is not a moral case refuting
I have
I immediately have questions. Did she just go for a run?
Did she put this coat on and then go for a run and then come
back?
Why is her hair now hanging down in her eyes? descending of so-called
Christian ethics. It is a legalistic one and nothing more. This
is important for you to understand.
>> For around a year, you've made repeated attempts to
drag me into a gender-based harassment project called the what
This I'm sorry. I'm sorry. This is what it looks like. It's why
did you show up in the literal
pervert flasher coat?
Why did you do this? Why did you do
It's weird.
You don't know fashion? I do know that this coat is like it just
seems odd for the video. It seems odd.
For around a year you've made repeated attempts to drag me into
a gender-based harassment project called the Whatever
Initially by reaching out directly, followed by a video designed
to provoke a response. And now, finally,
with an intimidation attempt where you branded me that terrifying
bogeyman your henchmen get so riled up about, a false
All of this is of course because I pride myself on refusing to
get my hands dirty by declining in no uncertain terms upwards
of 7 hours of male aggression captured on video on the other
side of the world. Let me make myself clear. This is because
I Did she get she got 50,000 viewer or 50,000 subs? Her set is
like one table, a lamp in the corner for a little back light.
She doesn't even have three-point lighting.
She's got a Yeti.
It's picking up all the breaths, too. What the hell? >> I am
above that. Not because I cast judgement on women who attend,
but because all women are above that. And I will encourage Did
we Somebody's got to do the edit of this that's just all of her
inhales.
To teach people about how you set up your audio, okay? That's
how you set up your audio chain. You You can't You can't be hearing
every intake of breath, man. That's every woman in my audience
to think the same of herself.
If that makes me a diva, Brian, I'm very happy to co-opt the
label.
What I'm about to do here is something much narrower and much
more necessary than an ethical debate with you on something so
archaic that most people aren't interested in taking a second
Mhm. I'm simply instead going to explain the law.
She's doing the Zizek bit. I watched a video on him talking about
how we don't debate anymore. We don't debate if it's okay anymore.
We actually don't. We're a polite society. We don't We don't
debate anymore. That's something we don't debate at all. We've
The debate on that is finished.
I've seen that. >> When people make public statements about
conduct within marriage, about whether consent exists between
spouses at all, or whether certain acts qualify as under modern
legal definitions. I won't avoid commentary on that, even in
the face of a hate campaign that brands me a liar who stages
abuse allegations against men to ruin their lives. That framing
is defamatory,
not mine.
This video is an exercise in laying out
Um I just wish So, if she did some research into this and she
wanted to say all of this, this is totally fine.
I I find it unbelievable that she wouldn't know now that the
wife in fact like consents to all of this dynamic.
Like the wife totally consents to this dynamic completely.
So, it's like by definition not
You could say the way he tells the story is wrong.
Right? He leaves out the part where she consented to the the
dynamic.
the law for a man in a community who need to hear it. To those
men, please feel free to campaign for a reversal of those laws.
I'll meet you on the opposite side of the rally face-to-face.
Because my rights are not granted to me, they are taken by me.
They ontologically belong to me. And I will speak to girls directly
before I address you, Andrew, for the simple reason that they
are more important than you will ever be.
She She said it that way just to undermine forced doctrine, which
is kind of funny. To my sisters, my friends,
Uh he does argue it's implied consent. Yeah, he does. my followers,
and to That should tell you a lot about Andrew Wilson, that he
doesn't get implied consent. He has actual consent, right? But
he's willing to argue you should be it should be implied in marriage
and try to create the implication that it is implied in his marriage
and he doesn't ask his wife, but in fact she does consent to
the whole thing. So,
it's it should tell you a lot about the performance he's putting
on. >> Women everywhere,
this man and his community are dangerous
Any reasonable man, any man who is worth your time is nothing
like him. Do not entertain them. Do not perform for them. Do
not fight on their turf. Fight them on your ground. Fight them
on the ground we're gaining. And do what they hate most. Say
no.
But of course, this video isn't moral
Yeah, that's fire. That's fire though. Do what they hate most.
Say no. offense of women's rights. It's Through a computer program.
Don't say no in person because that's actually what they do like,
okay? But through Skype, through Zoom, through
through a stream, through a video, say no remotely.
Where they can't do anything about it. >> reminder of pre-existing
legal precedent. So, let's put this fight aside for now and start
with the 2003
Offences Act.
Under section one of that act, a person commits three elements
are satisfied.
the person intentionally
another person's
or mouth with their
Ass or mouth, okay. Third, the person does not reasonably believe
that the other person consents.
Those three elements together form the legal structure of the
offense. What is
I mean, this is going to all come down to reasonability.
Now I could see how much you might be able to argue the law under
this.
Well, actually, it's probably reasonable for Andrew to believe
that his wife consents cuz they constantly talk about their philosophy
and how they what they believe about the world. And realistically,
I'm guessing she said multiple times that she does believe that
within marriage it's like implied consent unless explicitly denied.
So, realistically, between them, I'm sure he does
believe he has implied consent, and she probably also believes
the same. So, it's probably reasonable for him to suspect that
he has consent in those
So, now I can see why under this law
uh under this law this might be dicey. >> important for
the purposes of this discussion is what the statute does not
say. The statute contains no exception for marriage.
Wait, but what did Andrew what is you There's some of his wife's
statements out there. What did Andrew think his wife thought?
What do you think Andrew thought his wife What do you think about
that? Right? I
It's possible she gets by on this. Uh [__]
Is this not up for defamation? In the UK, possibly.
Cuz I don't think I don't know if it's possible that you could
say or and argue that you're basically arguing
that you don't believe that Andrew Wilson's wife thinks this
at all, like shares his views.
But she like objectively does. There is no clause stating that
spouses automatically
consent to
Yeah, but there's no law that says that, but they are married
and they've had this discussion. They've both built like entire
debate like empires on basically like this. >> activity
with one another. There is no legal doctrine within modern English
law that treats marriage as permanent or implied
permission. Consent must exist for each act of activity. That
principle is foundational within contemporary English criminal
law.
Historically, English law did contain what we call the marital
exemption. This
But you don't get to argue, even though he was arguing for marital
It's like two people believe that the marital exemption should
be there are married
and they have sex. That's like sort of an automatically unimplied
it's reasonable for them to presume consent unless otherwise
specified, right?
And that's really what this will come down to. It's not that
they're exempt for being married, which is what he was arguing,
I agree.
It was that they're exempt because it's reasonable for Andrew
to believe that she would consent unless otherwise
No, she's arguing about the law cuz she's saying she's not guilty
of defamation because he fulfilled all elements of the law.
She's not saying but she's arguing that reasonableness thing
is actually really funny. This doctrine originated centuries
ago and it was based on the idea that a wife gave irrevocable,
intractable
relations upon entering marriage. That doctrine was abolished
in 1991 in the landmark House of Lords case R v R. It was In
that case, the court ruled that the marital exemption was outdated
and incompatible with modern legal principles of autonomy, equality,
and bodily integrity.
If you spend some time in the manosphere, those words might sound
like a foreign language by now. But rest assured, Andrew, they're
not going
The ruling made clear
Ooh, I She's kind of
I like agree with all of her points, but the way she's arguing
this, it's like you're going to be right,
but nobody actually thought Andrew was winning the debate on
marital
Pretty much everybody like the forest doctrine stuff and basically
why it's a patriarchy and why patriarchy can't really be disassembled.
That's like a the sort of a false framing that is almost impossible
for him to lose in. And so I understand why he wins debates on
that and looks good to people on that one thing. But, for the
marital thing, that's like not somewhere people think force doctrine
applies. People don't believe in that. He broadly is not winning
people over on that. There will be like weirdos who will agree,
but there are always weirdos who would agree. This is like you
win this debate very easily, very obviously. But, that's not
that's not really what the the conversation should be.
Right? It's basically did you Did you say he violated UK law?
Right? Cuz you're you're basically
appealing to UK law. If he were to sue you in the UK, and I think
there's it's entirely reasonable to believe that you know that
he is not violating the UK >> that a husband can be guilty
of raping his wife under the same legal framework that applies
to any other person. And that principle has been firmly established
in UK law for more than 30 years. In fact, the US abolished the
same exemption state by state not long
This is awkward for obvious reasons. I can quote you directly
as stating the supposed extremist nature of modern consent laws
in a debate you partook in 3 years ago against Rob Noer, a position
you long continue to hold, which state Rob Noer. Rob is a Noer.
We all know Rob is a Noer. I'm a Noer. The Rob is a >> wife
should keep to her vow of unconditional consent.
This is a coercive and controlling
On the subject of marital laws, he asserted the following, quote,
"You claim extremism, but the extremism is the other direction.
You claim that it's extreme to hold people to their oaths, that
it's extreme for you if your wife says that we are of one flesh,
of one mind under God. I think the extreme part is that you think
that that oath can just be arbitrarily broken whenever they feel
like breaking it."
In the 18-minute video posted to your podcast channel, in which
you describe a quote implied consent in marriage, you also re
Why would it matter if it's coercive
Why It doesn't It literally doesn't
in this case, because his wife is like totally buying into that
as a thing they want to live with.
If his wife didn't buy into it at all,
then you could charge Andrew. Andrew could get in trouble for
this, right? But his wife believes that. They basically For all
intents and purposes, they are both consenting to a fair use
That's the fact.
So, you can argue that marital rape is bad all you like, and
Andrew can argue it's good. But Andrew isn't doing marital rape.
And Tilly is wrong to even pretend that he is.
Did I say fair use? I
I usually do it the opposite way when I'm going to say fair use,
I say free use. But now it is free use. Yes, the free use >> reinforces
this legally obsolete personal opinion.
The next step here is understanding what the law means when it
refers to consent itself.
Section 74 of the Offences Act provides the statutory definition.
The act states that a person consents if they agree by choice
and have both the freedom and the capacity to make that choice.
Two elements are therefore required: agreement by choice and
the capacity to choose. If either of those elements are missing,
the law considers the act non-consensual.
Now, the stat
Okay, I'll interested to hear how she talks around the idea that
So, she's going to try to argue that if his wife's sleeping and
he to her, that's non-consensual by definition cuz she doesn't
have the capacity to consent in the moment. But if she consents
beforehand, if there was an agreement
why are we judging that? And would we expect that if there it's
on record, basically Rachel Wilson has said this publicly, would
we expect a judge to rule against Andrew in this case? definition
deliberately focuses on autonomy. It requires that the person
involved is able to make a meaningful decision at the time that
the act
I don't think so. I don't think so. Bro, that basically like
tons of different BDSM putting a gag in somebody's mouth would
would basically be by that definition.
Without like a a specified safe word, but then how do you even
prove the safe word part? Like, there's a whole bunch of things
that you would have illegal and are totally in the UK if this
were the case, which with what I think she's about to argue.
>> Situations involving sleep or unconsciousness are particularly
important in the law of consent, with section 75 of the Offences
Act establishing evidential presumptions in circumstances where
a person cannot communicate consent. And, well, you guessed it,
one of the circumstances explicitly listed is where the complainant
was asleep or otherwise
The legal logic here is really straightforward.
A person who is asleep or unconscious due to intoxication
cannot actively make a choice. If someone lacks the capacity
to choose, the statutory definition of consent under section
74 cannot be satisfied. For that reason,
Uh no no no no no. No, the I think there's absolutely a legal
reading here where having
right? Having this specific consent arrangement that involves
when you do not like you have the autonomy and the capacity to
make the decision that when you are incapacitated, that person
is allowed to do that. You You made that decision. You consented
to that. And you're open to do that whenever you want to change
it whenever you want.
Reach a verbal consent agreement into litigating whether coercion
invalidates the initial agreement. Yeah, but it's it It's straight
up It doesn't.
Feel the thunder, roll the thunder.
>> You said earlier you can't do that. No, she didn't say
that. She's arguing with the language says. I'm saying the language
does include this. Like pretty objectively to me. She's just
arguing it doesn't.
She's reading into what is it? Capacity to consent? Autonomy
and capacity. She's reading in at all times that you have the
ability to say no at all times. But that probably isn't true.
There would be a lot of situations that people do get into where
they don't have the capacity to say no verbally at any given
time.
I do not believe all of those would be under the law.
No, she's not full of hell. She's actually just incorrect here.
She's actually just incorrect.
Where she's possibly Well, hold on. No, no, no, no, no, no, in
the US that's true, Porter Beller. But in the UK I do So, in
the UK I think if you are accusing somebody of a crime, they
have to meet the elements of the crime.
And I think Andrew
even like I think Andrew at this point now that she's trying
to stand on this and she's done research, I don't think you could
believe possibly that Andrew meets the elements of the crime.
Right? But she is arguing she's standing 10 toes down and saying,
"No, no, no, you meet all of the elements of this crime." But
he doesn't. Obviously this is like a publicity stunt. She's doing
this intentionally to generate views.
So obviously it's a publicity stunt. I don't think it really
goes anywhere. I think it'd be totally
for Andrew to sue her.
Yeah, I think UK US defamation law, she's got she's totally fine.
She's totally safe. Right? I think we're in the letter of the
law versus spirit of the law situation here.
In any case, I think she I think she might actually be up by
doing this, which is unfortunate. I don't think she should be
sued, though.
The Yeah, I don't think she should be sued for this.
I Although, I wish she would just back off, to be honest.
I I really wish he would back off and just go Obviously, you
guys could say I think the best video you can make here is No,
your wife has literally explicitly said she can she consents
to this. This is like your thing.
So, thank you for respecting your wife's autonomy, for not believing
in marital Even though you advocate for it, for not practicing
it, and respecting your wife's consent and her autonomy
on a personal level, Andrew. You're actually a better guy than
you pretend to be. I think that a catty video like that would
be very funny.
unfortunately, she went the other way. >> activity initiated
while a person is asleep, let alone passed out due to alcohol
consumption, is raising serious legal questions about whether
genuine consent existed at the time of the act.
You have proudly admitted to having sex with your wife while
she is asleep or unconscious due to alcohol consumption.
Let me reiterate this one more time to make it perfectly clear.
Section 74 defines consent as a choice made with freedom and
capacity.
Section 75 explicitly states that capacity is presumed absent
when a person is unconscious, unless proven otherwise. And Andrew,
you have stated on the record that you have sex with your wife
while she is passed out drunk. Unless proven otherwise. There
it is, right there.
Anybody who thought she was arguing then the fight We have proof
otherwise. We literally have proof otherwise. That exists.
So, for her to double down on this after such proof is given,
I do believe that
Andrew's wife has been like tagging her and stuff and saying
So, it's weird that she's going to continue arguing. If you just
want to say, this is my impression and now I don't Maybe she'll
save it by going, this was my impression. I now no longer think
this. Maybe she'll Oh, maybe she'll do this whole thing and then
she'll go the catty route that I suggested. Maybe.
Because of your belief in implied consent.
This is where your theology crashes into the statute. The law
does not recognize implied consent as a rebuttal to
>> Sorry, this is funny. This is funny for numerous reasons.
This is funny.
Didn't Destiny argue Didn't Destiny offer her 100k?
I know Destiny like offered her a 100k to defend herself, right?
100k down the drain.
In fact, it presumes the opposite. Hence, based on the statements
you have made publicly, in your own words, on your own platforms,
the conduct you described, if accurately described by you, would
satisfy the elements of a Section 1 offense under the Sexual
Offences Act
I'm not asserting that you committed a criminal offense, nor
am I asserting that you would be convicted.
I'm saying that a reasonable person, applying the statutory definition
to the conduct that you describe in your videos, could reasonably
reach that
Oh, hold on. Hold on. >> 2003. Sorry, I looked away for
a second. I'm not asserting that you committed a criminal offense,
nor am I asserting that you would be convicted.
Hold on. I do believe in UK defamation law, but if you are suggesting
that somebody's That is In the UK, that is more like the UK is
like Tek Tone's world, his ideal world, okay? I'm saying that
a reasonable person, applying the statutory definition to the
conduct that you describe in your videos, could reasonably reach
that conclusion.
An argument sometimes raised I think that's true.
That's true, but then you have to give away the other side of
this. If the fifth partner has discussed this beforehand,
for example, the night
that discussion then automatically resolves the question of consent.
Courts consequently examine whether the defendant could reasonably
believe that consent existed at the time of the act. Where someone
is unconscious
and unable to communicate, establish
Dude, um this girl's this girl's attitudes on consent and all
of this, it's very interesting that she's talking to Erudite
and
networking into this circle.
I do wonder how aware she is of certain things suddenly. What
is going on there?
Is this totally because obviously if she is going to be if she
has this kind of heat for Andrew,
you would assume,
Is it aware? I
The way she speaks, there's something about the way she speaks
that makes me think this is quite sincere and that it's quite
um
I don't get the impression that this is like an act. You don't
You don't start speaking this way as a woman
and not have like the sort of like principled definition of these
things. Get her on stream? I'm a misogynist. Why she Why would
she come on my stream?
I'd be crazy. significantly
more difficult because consent is about one's ability to refuse.
How a situation is described therefore becomes legally pivotal.
If a person explains that they initiate activity with a sleeping
or unconscious partner because of outdated presumptions regarding
marriage or because they enjoy the surprise or shock reaction
that follows, that they find it quote hilarious, which you did,
Andrew, in whatever debate number 11, followed by the statement
quote I 100% stand by this. This is not trolling and quote, it
says something pivotal. It says that the act that you described,
as you described it, was about power and even humiliation, not
just The description suggests that the initiating person expected
the other party to be unaware of and even avoidant of the act.
You reinforce your incorrect perception of consent once again
when at 5 minutes and 15 seconds of the video titled Andrew Wilson
is accused of S attacking his wife by radical feminist, you wrongly
state quote, "There's an implied consent when you get married.
It's implied that you're consenting to sex."
At 17 minutes and 50 seconds of the video, the feminist in question
states very reasonably that quote, "I think when we're talking
about experiences, consent is definitely the foundation in terms
of you're not only considering your experience, but you're also
considering your partner's."
You respond with quote, "No.
I'm just
This isn't just about you, it's about your partner, too. No,
it isn't.
Damn. considering mine. Like, I just want to have a good time."
Statements describing pain, surprise, or shock followed by a
resigned okay, which occurs at minute 15, are the cherry on top
of one of the creepiest interactions I've ever seen. You're not
even trying to frame your interactions as acceptable kink. You're
relying on Christian orthodoxy as a foundation, which has always
been at odds This is all true. He is He is trying to make the
other person grossed out that he is like a by their definition.
Now, he isn't he he's not like that. He is not relying on that.
She does consent to this dynamic, but he is trying to make the
other person feel grossed out, which is why before the thing
had come up come up about UK law, I thought she was totally fine.
Was Andrew was intentionally leaning into this and he was like
being performative about it, I thought that would like totally
kill him in terms of any legal case. >> with that community
for good reason.
As much as you might try to suggest, you are in actuality not
an expert in the gray areas one bit, which I know because your
own words make that absolutely clear. In fact, let's take a look
at a few of them now via Twitter. Quote, "Slipping off a condom
during isn't or even close." 6th of February, 2022. Quote, "If
taking off a condom stealthily during is not is putting a condom
on stealthily during 4th of February, 2022. Quote, "He insisted
that they have or he wouldn't be with her." is the opposite of
24th of October, 2024. Quote, "Intoxication isn't relevant. What
does coercion mean in this sense?" He asked a bunch of times,
"So what?" 9th of January, 2023.
And finally, quote, "Why get mad when I call my wife my property?
That's right, I own her. She belongs to me. I won't share her.
I won't give her away. I won't let other people steal her. I
won't let people damage her. And I make sure she is maintained.
Women must treat their things poorly to be offended."
19th of January, 2025.
Wait. K, I I sort of get the element that she's going I get what
she's going for a little bit.
I do think there's something to be said
for her reading the quotes instead of actually playing the clips.
I think she starts to look a little bit silly in some of these
situations when Andrew's like clearly laughing and like saying
something to be inflammatory, but she's doing the like courtroom
transcript read instead of the read it the way he says
right? Now,
more power to her if she just wants to make him look as bad as
possible, which clearly what's going on here.
I think
I dude, I'm like I'm like so close to being totally on board
with this video, but I just can't quite get there. >> Someone
consented to with a condom, stealthing doesn't amount to under
English law. Under the Serious Crime Act 2015,
coercive or controlling behavior is also a criminal offense.
Well, I can't charge you with a crime. Showing a pattern of ownership
language provides the necessary context for why a reasonable
person would recognize your views on consent as part of a larger,
more dangerous worldview.
And all of the above statements, both in and outside of their
full context, intersect directly with the legal framework surrounding
I mean, I've linked the videos referenced in the description
of this video just in case of skepticism, and viewers can of
course search for the tweets themselves. But in short, it doesn't
matter that you say your wife consented, or even if she says
she did, if there exists a wealth of statements that don't reflect
current legal precedent. And my commentary based on those statements
are therefore based on what had already been disclosed.
Okay, so at this point she's now basically that's a tacit admission
that she doesn't believe Andrew's actually
It's a tacit admission. And I I guess what she's going to I mean,
morally what she's going to argue is basically you're advocating
to make other people you're you're literally advocating for
for to do okay, that's what you're advocating for. You're advocating
for a world where more men get Andrew. So, you know what? I am
going to call you I am going to call you that. He just plays
one on TV type [__] >> People do often confuse
whether conduct meets the legal definition of an offense with
whether a criminal conviction would realistically occur.
Those are not the same question.
Courts regularly examine situations where one party describes
conduct in a particular way, but the legal definition of the
act raises questions about whether it constitutes an offense.
Especially in a domestic violence or coercive control context.
In my home
the police often become particularly concerned when wives seem
to hold steadfast to the belief that her husband is entitled
to her body at all times.
But regardless, if someone described conduct that met the legal
elements of
I'm I'll be honest. I'm I'm just checking some stuff out for
another segment. I am listening.
Is she arguing now that essentially
cuz this could be another argument she could try to make,
but it is tough. Is that the idea of like the the ideas that
Andrew preaches
leads to a world where women begin to lack the capacity to meaningfully
consent. That like once you've told the woman, your wife, that
you own her body, you get to do whatever you want, she starts
to her capacity to consent is actually diminished.
Like even if you could convince her of this, you're actually
doing some harm to her specifically by arguing these things because
it diminishes her capacity to consent meaningfully in the future.
of an assault such as having with someone who is intoxicated
to the point of unconsciousness due to a marital consent doctrine
underlaid by a clear belief in female obedience to male power,
then the fact that the victim said they personally did not mind
would not change a reasonable person's understanding
of the description itself, nor would it insulate you from commentary,
even though criminal convictions were not pursued because when
someone posts statements on a public platform that are likely
to flout legal standards on the basis of Christian moral opinion,
I am ultimately well armed when I advocate on behalf of what
the law actually means for wives. Whether you disagree with me
or not.
In other words, a lack of prosecution against you, Andrew, by
your benevolent wife, whose beliefs surrounding consent are severely
legally outdated, who believes consent can be quote "irretractable",
does not mean the legal framework is irrelevant or incorrect.
And it doesn't mean I defamed you. I I even quote you as understanding
this basic premise perfectly when it isn't about with your wife.
When you recently tweeted only a few days ago, quote, "On clavicular
getting smacked, the defense seems to be she asked if she could
slap him and he said yes, so there is no
If I ask to shoot you and you say yes and I do, is there no crime?
One of the replies to your tweet kind of sums it up. Quote, "It
makes you wonder if there are things that adults can't consent
to and if so, where's the line? Cuz I'd say yes, one can agree
to be slapped and it's not a crime, but one cannot agree to be
shot and it not to be a crime. The assumption being that a mentally
healthy person would not agree to be shot without some rational
Uh-oh. Uh-oh, she's coming for the this people now.
Going to start judging blacks.
Uh, a mentally healthy person would never agree to be while they're
asleep. A mentally healthy person would never do
Oh, that's a can of worms if she wants to argue this. If she
If she's going to go that direction, that's
that's going to be woof. So, they must not be mentally healthy,
making it exploitative by the other person.
It's food for thought, but I digress. Explaining how your belief
system surrounding consent relates to a troubling rejection of
what define under UK law, as is my right as a commentator, is
not the same thing as claiming a criminal conviction ever would
or did
Those are two different assertions.
Recognizing that distinction is essential if we want to discuss
the law accurately rather than emotionally.
But I understand we have a cross-border problem. You're American,
I'm British, it happens.
So, I'll go out of my way to emphasize a key point that exists
in UK criminal
Victims head don't have to see themselves as victims in order
for a charge to happen. In England and Wales, prosecution decisions
are made by the CPS, not by
In the UK, the police inv- Again, the I again, you can get around
the original statement. I feel like she's not made it very clear
that by the original statement is not sorry, that she disavows
the original statement, that she knows that Aerodite was not
in any danger or anything like that. She's not changed anything
around that at all. Right? What you call them a Like she's not
changed anything around it. And I do think once you look it up
and his wife says it's like uh yeah, free use dynamic. I do think
you sort of have to swap around a little bit. investigate, the
case is passed to the Crown Prosecution Service, and then the
CPS decides whether to prosecute. This means in practice that
even if someone says they don't want charges, the CPS can still
prosecute if there is enough evidence and if it is in the public
interest. This happens fairly often, actually, in domestic abuse
cases. The victim's cooperation can indeed affect how strong
the case is against her alleged attacker, but it does not legally
prevent investigation or
Yeah, but the crime is a violation of her of basically her word.
So, the the actual crime here is having sex with her without
her consent, but she has consented. So, you it to to rise above
that, her pre-consent
in this case, you basically have to convince them that Andrew's
a cult leader. I think that would be incredibly
Right? That's That would be like that borders on nearly impossible
to me, that you could go and have cops be convinced by Rachel
Wilson that actually she's Sorry, not be convinced by Rachel
Wilson, that she is fully within her rights to do this. That
seems crazy.
Right? That seems wild. She's basically saying, "Well, the victim
doesn't have to agree." It's like, "Yeah, but you'd have to get
them to agree she's a victim, right?" And that's really easy
in child abuse cases,
but it would be incredibly hard with an adult woman who has kids
with Andrew.
Like a kid with Andrew and then other
And they have like a family and a business and all this [__]
And like she does a whole bunch of work for this. Like for her
to be some sort of like cult like brainwashed person, I just
don't see it. >> this isn't primarily about what decisions
Rachel may or may not make. I'm making a broader legal point
that the way that reasonable people interpret criminal law does
not have to relate to the private beliefs or preferences of the
people involved.
Mhm, it doesn't have to, but you have to give a reason why it
shouldn't. The cops have to suspect that that person can't have
their own opinion, that they're influenced in some way such that
they can't make their own opinion up. There's so they can't make
up their mind up,
She's saying it doesn't necessarily have but I mean it does.
Right? And specifically, what is a what it what Oh, hold on.
She's she's trying to be really slippery here, I think. I think
she's trying to like basically go around the issue entirely.
I shouldn't say slippery. She's trying to like avoid what she's
what she already said. So when she read the three elements, one
of them was
Third, the person does not reasonably believe. Third, the person
does not reasonably believe that the other person
you do you don't necessarily have to take into account like private
thoughts, but like public statements, what you know about these
two people beforehand, that probably should come into into play.
That probably should matter.
Right? It's actually
she's basically saying, "Oh well, it's about what broad people
would reasonably believe."
No, it's It's what the person
The person does not reasonably believe that the other person
consents.
But the the wife has said, "No, no, no, we have this dynamic."
So you you're basically saying, "No, no, no, but Rachel doesn't
even know. She She doesn't have the capacity to consent. She
is like a child. She can't consent cuz she's brainwashed.
So we're going to step in as the state in this fully functioning
family unit.
Right? It's
I don't think that's reasonable.
I I don't think what she's saying now is
to be honest with you. That it doesn't have to actually pertain
to his state of mind.
Like to By that logic,
you could say that somebody who is like prudish when it comes
to sex, if there was like some BDSM act that happened, and there
was a filmed video beforehand saying, "I consent to this and
all of this." A bunch of like that, right? And then they did
it, and that person lacked the capacity to consent and accused
the the person them in whatever the act is. Let's say they're
tied up, they've got a gag in their mouth or something. That
is and you think the cops would go, "Oh, despite the video pre-consenting
to this exact act, um I actually I It doesn't matter cuz I don't
I don't think stuff like this is cool. I think nobody would agree
to this unless they're mentally unwell. So actually that person's
a now." That's the argument she's making. That seems insane to
me.
That seems totally wild that you believe that. I don't think
you do believe that. I think you're I think you've gotten a little
bit of
I think she wants to stand up as this I could have She could
have easily said, "Now I've The video could have just been, 'Now
I've been made aware that your wife did consent. And while I
think she has diminished capacity because of uh because of her
faith, because of how you are as a husband, I will respect that
and say that I don't think you're right. But here are all the
reasons that I think you empower and make the world worse for
women in every way, and then she just does the same video.
But this feels like she's trying to go around and make like a
a roundabout argument towards why she wouldn't be held legally
culpable or why like legally a person would believe that he's
in the UK. And it's like, uh, I actually don't think this is
a good argument in
And I think it's mostly being given because you don't want to
say anything you don't even want to come close to saying you
might have been a little bit wrong to say that. Nate, I'm making
a broader legal point that the way that reasonable people interpret
criminal law does not have to relate to the private beliefs or
preferences of the people
See, she says doesn't have to. But it like obviously would in
this
In fact, it's almost it's almost implied by the law,
The person reasonably expects the other person or reasonably
thinks the other person would consent.
Didn't actually say anything. No, she is saying things. You're
just not listening. She's not just being vague. She's She is
trying to say that like, "Oh, here's why I could believe this
or why you might be charged under the law." But it's not going
to matter if that's not the case. I don't I don't think she really
believes this. I think she's
Yeah, I don't think she believes this. It's like not a good >> in several
areas of the law, but especially when it pertains to domestic
abuse, coercive control, and offenses, the state applies objective
legal standards even when the individuals involved say everything
is fine.
But again,
you would need a compelling reason to. Like, you she's trying
to she's totally smuggling this in. Yeah, if a woman's got a
black eye and a fat lip, and she goes, "Nothing happened. This
is all fine." Well, you see something is wrong. You can make
a decision to go against what they're saying. But they literally
have like a happy marriage. They've got kids. They've been doing
this for a long time.
That there's no reason. There's no reason to ignore what she's
saying. There's no reason to say she's wrong.
In grooming cases, for example, a victim may appear to agree
to what is
They may even articulate that agreement, but the law looks beyond
that surface to the surrounding dynamics like dependency, manipulation,
and the gradual normalization of behavior that would otherwise
be resisted. I totally I understand what she's saying, and I
do agree with her on these points. This clearly doesn't apply
to Rachel Wilson. I'm sorry.
Like I agree with you that the law should be this way, and it
probably almost certainly is this way in a lot of places, right?
That you could have like a cult member who can't consent to something
meanly or meaningfully. I do not believe that Rachel Wilson has
shown herself to be like a total cult member who who has no capacity
to make decisions on her own. I don't think that's the case.
I think that's you talking around the issue to make it seem like
it was okay to say this. And while I think it was okay if you
were more controlled about it, "Hey, this guy enables everywhere.
This guy's a total piece of who enables every" Yeah, that would
be fine. I think that's accurate in fact.
But you weren't controlled. You were emotional about it or you're
doing a stunt, one of the two. And now you're trying to double
down, and I don't think it's a good double down.
I mean, the point is simple. The power and acceptance does not
settle the question of consent. Whether there is a structured
imbalance of power or a pattern of coercive influence, the law
is willing to say that what looks like agreement is not in fact
freely given consent at all. So even if two people personally
believe that a certain practice is okay, such as the idea that
marriage implies consent forever, us as commentators are still
permitted to evaluate the situation using the statutory definition.
The law does not change simply because two individuals privately
interpret it differently. The law does not give a [__]
that you're a Christian nationalist.
The law exists
She's arguing I I think there's basically ideas under the law.
I mean, I guess we'll see. Now I kind of want Now I I don't want
her to get sued cuz I think it's gross. But um now I kind of
want to see the legal case play out cuz I just like to see how
it goes. I think she's basically taking an area where somebody
would have deference to make a call in the moment.
And for her, I think she's saying like she's taking and she's
applying that as if she could go away from the statute. I think
technically they can do things, but they apply on a case-by-case
basis. And she's saying, "Well, it doesn't have to go this way."
But it obviously would go this way. And she's not actually commenting
on what she believes in this
She might say like Rachel Wilson couldn't possibly consent. She
might She but I really I think if she said that, she'd probably
make similar arguments for essentially like all I think she'd
say something like, "Yeah, you know, we live in a patriarchy.
Women have a hard time consenting in a patriarchy." I think she'd
make similar arguments to that. >> Precisely because it
is an enforcement mechanism for clear boundaries that cannot
be altered by private indoctrination.
I mean, I've got I'm guiding you to the inevitable here, Andrew.
Unfortunately for you, it's a clear-cut case that people who
publicly describe behavior that interacts with legal boundaries
are going to meet someone like me one day who can't be intimidated
with a legal threat, which is bound to crash and burn. I'm just
one of many listeners who evaluated the statements that you posted
to the internet using the legislative framework that exists in
my country.
That is the basis on which I made my
Why is she dressed like a Jedi?
Maybe she just hasn't done her laundry in like 2 weeks. She doesn't
have any clean outfits.
I don't know. I don't know. The same principles that I outlined
so far apply in multiple intersecting fields, too. In contract
law
She's technically No, she's not even Well, she's Yeah, she's
saying something like this, Portobello.
She's basically arguing like multiple edge cases to laws where
possibly they could be interpreted this way.
But I think there's reason to believe that they wouldn't be interpreted
this way. Tons of reason to believe they wouldn't be interpreted
this way. Right? She's literally doing when piss when Pisco says
"Okay, it's possible, but is it probable?" She's doing a possible
thing. It's technically possible that it could
And so in terms of the spirit of the argument she's like kind
of being just a total piece of [__]
In my opinion. All agreements must
Like I Yeah. >> to specific terms and specific transactions.
Agreeing to sell one item does not imply consent to sell future
items. Agreeing to a contract today does not automatically bind
someone to future unrelated agreements.
In tort law, the defense of consent to risk is similarly limited.
If someone consents to one risk in one situation, that consent
cannot be expanded beyond the specific context in which it was
given. Consent is bounded and it's
One of the clearest parallels comes from medical law itself,
despite your disturbing tweets suggesting otherwise.
So all CNC is according to Tilly by this by this definition by
this argument. In Montgomery v. Lanarkshire Health Board, the
UK Supreme Court emphasized that patients have to give informed
consent to specific medical procedures, which means doctors cannot
rely on general permission or assumed agreement or even previous
discussions that did not cover the exact procedure performed.
Consent has to be informed, specific, has to be given in relation
to the particular act. Again, the law rejects the idea that general
permission carries forward indefinitely. But medical law isn't
quite the same. I will grant you that. It
She Oh, this is funny.
Yeah, how do you How do you sign over like the ability to make
decisions for you? End-of-life care and stuff like that, right?
That's kind of funny.
Like she She basically knows that there's an obvious counterargument
to what she's saying.
But I would just say
Do you believe that all C&C is Do you believe that's the
policy of the of the UK government?
Do you believe that this is how it is applied in the UK?
And I And I would have to ask for a yes or no, cuz I feel like
all she would do there is dance, right? That's all she would
do. And she would never ever answer that question directly. She
would just dance around
I don't think she thinks so. >> It actually operates under
a slightly different model. And that's because medical consent
is procedural, purpose-bound, and professionally
Consent, unlike medical consent, must exist at the time of the
act. It must involve capacity in the moment itself, and it cannot
be assumed on the basis of marital status or permanently granted.
Why? Precisely because medicine is documented and under constant
regulation, and sex is none of those things. It is exactly
activity lacks institutional safeguards that UK law requires
clear consent at the moment that the act occurs.
Which means you need
Um I would argue
I I'm sorry, I would say you could argue this. I think there
is an argument there that because it's between two parties that
any specific act has to be consented to because explicitly like
there could be patterns of abuse that unfold and just giving
people the out whenever that abuse is occurring might be helpful.
Maybe maybe I could see like what she's
But that's not the way it is. I could I could even understand
somebody arguing that that would be better if it were that way.
That would produce harm.
I don't I don't think anybody really thinks it is that way. >> all
times to possess the ability to say
And in fact like realistically unless this is happening on camera
it's happening in like a closed room between two people anyway.
And so realistically
it almost
in terms of the law it's really not terribly different unless
you have a contract written out.
So too in property law permission to enter land is limited just
like your permission to enter a woman. I think it will further
aid your comprehension in fact if I list some specific examples
of events that may or may not describe as defined in English
law which may which might relate to statements you have made
in the past. This is a game. You can play along with it. Simply
shout out yes or no before I reveal the answer. Number one.
A man and a woman both get drunk and agree to have However, once
the woman arrives at the man's house she falls unconscious due
to her intoxicated
She's going to totally ignore the fact
after this you find out there's a video released of them talking
beforehand and the woman tells the guy actually no matter how
drunk I get I need you to [__] me right now. Actually
they've known each other for years. They've been married. They've
got kids and she was like no matter how drunk I get you you have
you have to [__] me after this. It's like the hottest
idea in my head.
So put that into the scene right now. Okay? Hated state. The
man has with her
Ready with your answer? It's yes. Under English law this is considered
because the woman's intoxicated state has removed her ability
to reverse consent. In England, any earlier agreement is irrelevant
once capacity is lost. And where a I don't believe that.
I I don't believe that.
I I straight up don't believe it.
It It has to be different than that or like there's just tons
of happening in the UK that could be prosecuted any given time.
And you have no defense for. Which I don't think I don't think
she's really doing it this way, okay? >> a person is unconscious,
they are presumed not to consent and the defendant is presumed
to know this.
Number two. A man and a woman are having marital problems. It's
been a while since they had The woman's husband tells her, "If
you don't have with me right now, I'm going to file for divorce."
He has a consistent pattern of threatening divorce if his wife
does not have with You ready with your answer? It's a
I mean, yeah, I think that's way more coercive control. I think
that's way more than two people having this dynamic. Yeah, I
think that's bad, obviously bad. Yes. A repeated pattern of threatening
divorce for refusal can amount to coercion but negate consent.
Meaning that any apparent agreement may be legally invalid and
the act can
Yeah, I would agree with that. I would agree on that one. That's
like clearly some form of coercion that's outside of the
I think that's way different. The coercion is compounded where
the threat of divorce operates within some kind of context. A
context like a strongly anti-divorce community, dependency over
children, or even immigration vulnerability, such that Yeah,
yeah, that's all That's all great. Yeah, I totally agree with
her on this.
Feel like she thinks she was going to get us. She thought she
was going to get us that the first one was way more obvious than
the second one. No, the second one's more obvious than the first
Well, the first one absent if they met that night, probably.
The first one is also very obvious. >> Refusal carries
cascading social, legal, economic consequences.
eliminating any genuine ability to say
Number three, and this is the last one. A man and a woman agree
to have on the Uh-oh. Uh-oh.
Did she try to get me that like Andrew by saying it's a it's
a right of a husband is threatening Just right.
Technically doing rape.
And using the threat of divorce by saying this is your wifely
duties to coerce her at all times. >> On the condition
that a condom is worn. Halfway through the act, the man secretly
takes off the condom and continues to have sex with the woman
who only finds out later that this occurred. You ready with your
answer? It's yes, because consent is conditional. And where a
person agrees to sex only on the condition that a condom is worn
Ooh. Ooh. Ooh. Ooh.
Is she going to do the trans one then? That would be funny.
Woman who is um FTM.
Obvious implication being that there's an agreement that you're
a Right? Right? Deliberately removing it invalidates that consent.
Meaning that the act occurs without consent under the Sexual
Offences Act.
If you have committed any of these acts, that fact pattern can
amount to If you have admitted to committing any of these acts,
you have admitted to a fact pattern that can amount to
If you believe any of these acts do not constitute That means
you are, might have, or may in the future
Does she do like the compounding, the the moral compounds?
Cuz what what does she think about the
A guy drops an ATM slip, okay? They do the Frank Reynolds bit
from It's Always
That you know, 300 grand in his checking
drops his ATM slip and the woman sees it and then they have sex,
but he actually was carrying a fake ATM slip that is actually
like he's got zero dollars. He's actually in ruinous debt. Okay,
he sees woman thinking that this woman is or this woman sees
him thinking that he's totally into it. Uh Rotimus, thank you
for the gifted. Uh we by the way, we still need other six six
gifted to go for another hour after this just so we will know.
Anyway, it's um
Is that right?
Hold on, even less. That's Hold on, even less. She just said
it was. She just argued. Yeah, she Hold on. The condom thing,
no? She said What did she say about the condom thing? Hold on.
If you have committed any of these acts, that Oh, hold on. Wait
a minute. >> ability to say no.
Number three, and this is the last The man secretly takes off
the condom and continues to have Listen to what she >> with
the woman who only finds out later that this occurred. You ready
with your answer? It's yes, because consent is conditional and
where a person agrees to sex only on the condition that a condom
is worn,
Cuz consent is conditional is the way she said it. Consent is
conditional.
I would say
with regards to your physical health, it's got to be conditional.
Like condoms are sort of a carve out there. Otherwise, I don't
believe you get to do conditions like that. Right? It's got to
be conditional on specifically your physical health. As in like
you could get an STD, you are agreeing to this on the idea that
you would not be that you will do harm reduction. That person
will do harm reduction. But then they don't do harm reduction.
Yeah. Anyway.
deliberately removing it invalidates that consent, meaning that
the act occurs without consent under the Offences Act.
If you have committed any of these acts, that fact pattern can
amount to If you have admitted to committing any of these acts,
you have admitted to a fact pattern that can amount to
If you believe any of these acts do not constitute That means
you are, might have, or may in the future meet the statutory
bar for conviction. If you believe any of these acts are okay
if you do them to a spouse
See, she's now arguing that if you say that these acts are okay,
that you are that I can call you a I don't think that's the way
the UK law works for defamation.
That means you might have, or may in future meet the statutory
bar for
It's very important that your audience understands this to protect
them. Because many men don't want to be perpetrators, and nobody
wants to be a
These examples reflect a broader legal principle that agreement
is tied to the specific circumstances in which it is And it's
about possessing the freedom and the ability to say no before
something happens to you. Consent is never indefinite. This is
why the argument that agreement at one moment implies
I would say also the um There's like more in here. I'm probably
I'm nitpicking because I don't like that she won't just basically
say
Yeah, you guys have a dynamic and it's it is what it is. That
she has to do the thing where she's like, well, but your wife's
like indoctrinated. She's a total
No, she's not. This was sending feet pics to people on Twitter
like 5 years ago. She's not indoctrinated at all. Come on.
Come on.
You know what I'm saying? I'm probably closer to her ideas of
consent than Andrew's. Well, sorry, I'm definitely closer than
Andrew's, but even to like what my opinion would would seem like
Probably like far closer to her. I um I really don't like that
she's basically
she's trying to construct these like pretty elaborate arguments
to just not be like ah you're probably not a racist.
I I just feel like that kind of ego is always bad. You're so
unwilling to admit that maybe something you said was a little
wrong, little wrong to do, that you got to like double down.
I don't know. permission later even in the context of marriage
gets you in some seriously hot water. And it's why Rachel
presents herself as an antidote to the statements covered. But
her comments are unfortunately extraneous to the argument I'm
making in this video. And arguments I made on Tyler's live stream.
The suggestion that if a wife says she has granted permanent,
irrevocable, irretractable consent to her body, then any criticism
of her husband's actions must be defamatory legally doesn't
You didn't describe his actions though. You described You described
an action he didn't do.
That's That's the problem. If you said you There's so many different
ways,
There's so many different ways.
She will apologize for it right when a guy she likes does it.
That is her phenotype. That's a crazy thing to say baby poison.
Uh I just think Tilly should be just as if not more concerned
about that. Well, obviously yes. Obviously that's true substance.
I think the operating theory she has no idea what happened with
the Destiny stuff. I think that's the obvious operating theory.
To be like associating with even Kyla,
I think I think even Kyla's general conduct there has been pretty
pretty rough, man. Pretty despicable.
So, and I see it warn her surely.
Yeah, surely. Surely. Surely.
And arguments I made on Tyler's live stream. The suggestion that
if a wife says she has granted permanent, irrevocable, intractable
consent to her body, then any criticism of her husband's actions
must be defamatory, legally does not follow because the law doesn't
see irrevocable consent as a real thing ever. So, let's talk
about defamation law. In English defamation law, the court asks
>> Oh, maybe maybe she'll totally maybe she'll totally
boom me on defamation law. Maybe she's totally got me on defamation
law. We'll see. >> complained of Cuz cuz I was just operating
off of like what I've heard Queenie men say before and then I
think
Destin Suggs came in and was like, "Oh, yeah, Queenie men said
this is the way defamation law works in the UK. I thought she
wouldn't be covered." I was like, "Oh, yeah, I've heard something
like this." But maybe I don't understand and maybe she can woman
explain it to me, okay? >> defamation law. In English defamation
law, the court asks whether the statement complained of falls
within one of the recognized statutory defenses.
Let's go with the honest opinion defense
Under section three of the Defamation Act, a defendant has a
defense if three conditions are satisfied.
Firstly, the statement complained of was an opinion, not a statement
of verifiable fact. Secondly, the opinion
[__] I have to >> has a defense if three conditions
are
Firstly, the statement complained of was an opinion, not a statement
of verifiable fact. Secondly, the opinion
you I she she's out on that first one just by her entire argument
here that argues that it's reasonable under the law, right? >> opinion
indicated the basis on which it was made.
Thirdly, an honest person could Oh, wait. statement complained
of was an opinion, not a statement of verifiable fact. Secondly,
the opinion indicated the basis on which it was made.
Now, did she do that? I think she said eventually she says eventually
she gets to based on the things he said, right? I think she says
that eventually.
Maybe maybe that gets her safe,
Thirdly, an honest person could have held that opinion based
on the facts that existed at the time.
The third requirement is crucial. The law does not ask whether
the opinion is universally accepted or whether everyone would
agree with it. It asks whether a reasonable person could reach
that
Oh, that's way different than what I was led to believe about
UK law. If that's the case, if if it's not like a
if it's not sort of like a defamation per se thing and it's just
could a reasonable person believe this based on what Andrew said,
then yeah, absolutely.
If that if it's that simple that you just basically can say,
oh, would a reasonable person believe this based on what Andrew
said, then yeah, it doesn't even really get into anybody else's
I don't know why she went through the whole thing. She already
won on this.
Why did she just go to this? Based on the underlying facts. Now,
if someone publicly describes in a very long recorded discussion
completing with a partner while she is asleep or unconscious
due to alcohol consumption
justifying this at any point with an outdated marital consent
narratives, those statements form part of the factual basis on
which listeners may form opinions. And Andrew, because you cannot
stop tweeting, you keep building that case over and over and
over.
Where the opinion I mean it doesn't really have to be built up.
You can just have the one video.
I think I think like as but then you probably have to come back
and say, so now I I know you're not. Now that I have more information,
now I know you're not. I don't know if you could go through all
the the what do you call it like the times Rachel said and go,
well, you built this up cuz I could have thought this at the
time, right?
But then Rachel cracks and you go, well, Rachel's like a totally
mind victim actually. So, I'm going to keep saying it. I don't
think those two jive. Now, I think you lose all of those previously
held defenses.
Now, I don't think you're operating in the realm of reasonability.
>> opinion expressed by a commentator is clearly tied to
those statements, in other words, whether reasoning is explicitly
explained, which it demonstrably was, then the honest opinion
defense becomes extremely strong because it satisfies that first
premise of the defense.
And as I continue to make clear, even if your bride states that
she personally views your conduct as consensual, that does not
automatically invalidate the legal analysis behind the opinion
because the law does not recognize permanent marital consent.
Rachel's subjective feelings, they are her own, but the CPS in
England doesn't ask a victim for permission to define what a
crime is. They look at whether the elements of the statute were
met.
But before I continue, I do want to speak to Rachel directly.
Just for a moment here. I don't expect a kind response, but that
doesn't matter to me cuz you are an adult woman, two decades
my senior, who has made a series of decisions, and I'm not here
to talk down to you because my point isn't You literally just
spent a bunch of time arguing that it's reasonable to suspect
that she's like a totally brainwashed
like sheep that's in a cult.
And Andrew is the sheep shepherd, okay. >> doesn't matter.
It does. And that's why the law operates how I've outlined. It
exists precisely to protect people who have been conditioned
not to see themselves as needing protection.
But your loyalty to him, your loyalty to Andrew is yours for
nobody to take, and I can see that it's ever present. You, like
every woman, have the right to autonomy, and that includes not
being spoken over by women with positive intentions.
Nobody should tell you what to do.
But they should remind you that your body was always yours first,
that you deserve more,
that you deserve better.
What you do with those reminders are in your hands. And I can
promise you that whatever you say in response to this, however
vicious or hateful or bored or dismissive, will not be taken
by me as a personal attack. And of course, you may never hear
this, but that's okay, too. I said it anyway.
Allow me to continue. My analysis is based on the potential claimant's
own recorded description of events,
the legal definition of consent under English law, and my interpretation
of those facts as a speaker.
This means that the presence of disagreement from another participant
does not transform that opinion into defamation, especially given
It doesn't transform it, but you do have to take that into account
and decide what you want to like say now. I do believe that a
correction is owed if she comes out and says this. And I think
we got a 40-minute video in response because you didn't want
to do that. The debates about the meaning of conduct described
in recorded statements frequently involve precisely this kind
of disagreement.
If you can't take the aforementioned heat, Andrew, perhaps next
time you should think twice before you describe over the course
of over 18 minutes what, according to the quote woke feminist
definition of consent, I just I wonder if she thinks like the
idea that Kylo was at risk of being for going on the Whatever
podcast because she went on the Whatever podcast, and then some
additional cope about how like, well, actually, I've heard they
like threatened not to pay people for like they keep them there
for like 7 hours, they keep them trapped in the desert. Like
that whole diatribe, she sounds deranged for that, okay? That
whole diatribe sounds deranged.
And she's like sort of zeroed in on just Andrew's statements,
but she added a bunch of other things in there,
And I I think it's really unreasonable for her to have this opinion.
Overall, the opinion she specified,
I think it's even more unreasonable now that Andrew's corrected,
or sorry, now now that Andrew's wife has corrected, and this
whole video was basically to "I was okay to say this, and I don't
want to I don't want to say no, no, no, I don't think so anymore."
and otherwise known as the statutory definition in England and
Wales, was conduct that under UK English consent
many listeners would interpret as meeting the legal definition
of
It makes your out-of-context argument appear ever more bizarre,
given that it's unclear why a reasonable person would interpret
a 20-minute video posted by your own close friend as out of context,
nor would they interpret explicit statements that marriage Wait,
did she know Wait, was she aware of all this
I feel like Uh, I feel like there's another thing here, which
is kind of funny. Do you think she's like actually aware of all
these things beforehand, or do you think she saw like one Tik
Tok clip of Andrew Wilson saying, "Yeah, I don't understand consent
the way you do. I can do whatever I want with my wife. I [__]
her while she's sleeping."
I I feel like that's the only clip she
and she's sort of reverse engineering her ability to say this,
and going and finding other stuff to build up the argument that
it's okay to say this.
But just like she didn't know about Rachel's statements, or what
Rachel
she also is una- she was also almost certainly unaware of all
of those videos. which implies consent throughout a video posted
in 2022 with Rob Noer, are simply repeatedly occurring out of
The Noers. And this was a video where Rob asked you what would
happen if your wife decided she didn't consent to and you replied
with quote, "So an oath is worth nothing now."
Courts take context seriously when evaluating defamation claims.
You're right, but context does not mean that a speaker's own
extended explanation of their position can be ignored.
Listeners like me are not relying on a single isolated clip.
They're hearing you describe your reasoning, your behavior, your
own views in your own words, both written and spoken, over an
extended period of time. From what I can see, at least 3 years.
Because the key legal point is not whether everyone agrees with
my interpretation. Your community obviously agrees with you.
The key question is whether the opinion
was based on identifiable facts, honestly held, and capable of
being reached by a reasonable person considering those facts.
Your community and If you keep saying that, and that's true,
but then given the updated facts, you have to agree that it's
not
You should agree. That is That is the way this works. I can give
you charity on you not knowing that they have that free that
free use dynamic, but then once it's clarified for you, for you
to continue to ignore it or just say she's like mine, right?
I don't think that's appropriate.
Yeah, I just don't think it's >> not representations of
reasonable
They are individuals rallying around a man who, in answer to
a question about what happens if his wife can doesn't consent,
responds with quote, "So an oath is worth nothing now." He tweets
that stealthily removing a condom isn't even close to who says
a man asking for repeatedly has nothing to do with coercion or
making no room for the existence of coercive control, who describes
his wife as property he owns, who believes obedience is a necessity
in marriage, defining it as doing whatever he wants, whenever
he wants, with a woman who has almost minimal input, who initiated
with an intoxicated unconscious woman, informed by his belief
in an archaic doctrine surrounding marriage, and described it
publicly with pride, despite unconsciousness requiring an extremely
high burden when it comes to proving consent, which goes far,
far beyond the irrevocable or implied.
Who then branded a woman who commented on those statements a
false accuser and threatened to sue her.
Andrew, my comments refer to statements you made publicly about
conduct within marriage. My point was that based on those statements,
I believe the behavior you described Okay, she's coming off as
self-righteous. Yeah, obviously.
I mean, she is self-righteous.
I I can understand as a woman, like I understand a woman being
like this upset about the [__] Andrew's saying. Like
as a guy, it's not really a big deal. I understand a woman who
like this guy is literally arguing that women should be property
again. I understand being like self-righteous and angry about
it. Makes
Due to a belief system that you hold surrounding marriage as
a marker of automatic or implied consent would meet the legal
definition of under English law. I was not claiming personal
knowledge of any criminal offense or asserting that a conviction
had occurred. This would of course be incredibly unreasonable
to interpret given that my comments directly arose in response
to a question about why I have declined invitations to appear
on your show. Any claim of reputational harm would also need
to account for the fact that the clip was repeatedly amplified
by you yourself, including edited repost of my claims to a much
larger audience than the original stream reached. In doing so,
you actively leveraged the controversy to generate traffic within
your community.
Which kind of complicates any suggestion that reputational harm
arose from the original content.
No, it doesn't.
I'm sorry, okay.
If No, I don't think so. I'm sorry. I don't think so.
I I I really hate that argument. Um, I just punched you in the
face. No, no, no, hold on, not that, not that, not
I called you a slur. You complained about that publicly. You've
actually You're not even outraged, and I couldn't have possibly
done any harm to you because uh maybe maybe slur is not right.
[__] reputational harm, defamation, actual damages.
Uh I'm trying to think of a good example. It's basically like
complaining about the thing I did does not renders your complaint
invalid. It doesn't. It doesn't. No, no, no, it
Private health it doesn't.
Especially um especially if Andrew needs money to like actually
fight that.
Okay, I think we're what? We got five or so minutes left.
I should really get on to Kick only. It's actually so [__]
annoying Kick died earlier, and I lost everybody.
>> itself was made during an informal live stream discussion,
and I explicitly explained to the basis of my view by referencing
your own publicly available statements about consent.
So, good luck. You'll need it because, as you similarly put it
to me on Twitter, I'm a kind woman, not a particularly nice one.
Throughout this video, I've taken behavior that millions of women
have experienced and that entire communities have been told is
biblical, legally untouchable, normal,
and shown methodically on the record that it isn't.
This video is therefore not a response to some influencer beef
thing. It's a resource for women and girls who have been told
that their bodies belong Still is 369. Yeah, it's fine. >> husbands
and boyfriends,
that objecting to sex is breaking an
women who have never heard the word Section 74 or the case R
v R, who don't know what coercive control is, who have been told
that obedience is a function of a healthy relationship.
It is the language that they've been
Language that you and everyone who came to your defense have
denied them.
As I've made clear, I'm not so familiar with US law. It is not
my country. What I do know is that in England and Wales, a person's
private beliefs about what the law should be do not change what
the law actually is. Your grandiose sense of entitlement does
not somehow overrule the long-standing legal principle often
summarized as ignorance of the law is no
If someone believes that tax laws do not apply to them, that
belief does not make tax evasion legal even if they think they
have a special divine right not to pay them.
If someone believes that speed limits are unnecessary,
that belief does not make driving at excessive speed lawful.
That's because there's an objective measure and these this is
by far this is by no means an objective measure. Consciousness
or or capacity or autonomy, they're not objective they're not
objective.
And there's no reason to believe from the reading of the law
that an agreement beforehand is invalidated
um because you have become unconscious especially when that agreement
is explicitly detailed to mean when I when I do not have
Right? Like if you didn't have an agreement, if you had like
a yeah. No, no, no. It's like if the agreement is specifically
when I'm not conscious, this is fine. Then saying well now you're
rendered unconscious and you can't consent and that couldn't
be something you would could agree to, I think that's absurd.
It's obviously absurd.
Is that your Discord noises? Yeah, I did turn Discord on for
myself. I was turning it on in the background while I was talking.
Yep yep.
That's me.
No, that's me. That's me. That's me.
That was all me. I'm in my Discord at this point, so okay. All
right.
I I Yeah, I'm just not a fan. I'm not a fan of like the arguments
she's making. Even if they think God has bestowed upon
No, no, no, no, no, Road to Miss, that that is not required.
That is not required, okay? In American court. If we're in American
court, Andrew would be totally cooked.
Now, I I super don't care if she calls him like a overall, but
if she's trying to be like good faith about it, I think when
when he's talking about a specific situation and then his wife
comes out and says, "Actually, we just consented the whole time."
Then you can go, "Oh, well, I didn't know that."
But it's it's totally fair for her not to assume. You know what
I'm saying? Like I think it's totally fair for her, if she hadn't
seen the wife saying, "I consent this uh for you, Stannumic."
If if she'd never seen that, it's totally reasonable for her
to have that
As soon as that opinion comes out, I'm like, "Okay, you should
If if they're act asking for a retraction cuz it there's reputational
harm, you should just retract and say, 'But also, I think you're
a total piece of [__] And I do think you're going
to cause people to in the future.'" Which is totally reasonable.
Again, upon them a particularly fast car.
If someone believes marriage implies consent, that belief does
not make their interpretation of marriage and access
Even if the individual's wife states that she has granted unconditional,
irrevocable access to her body on the same legally outdated basis.
This is why under the Sexual Offences Act, the question is not
merely whether a defendant personally believes consent is woke
because marriage implies
Bible bashing about a forever oath would never satisfy a court,
at least not in England, because the legal system has explicitly
rejected the idea that marriage creates ongoing
The broader principle is therefore quite
I took dude, I don't How far after did she say that? Not that
far. Not like terribly far, but she had a bunch of other factors
as well that I thought were fairly absurd. Like the opinion is
fairly absurd to give in my opinion. Except unless it's just
given his
simple. But even then, it's like basically I think Andrew his
wife and then the wife comes out and says, "No, no, no, it's
fine. I consent." You go, "Well,
well, I don't actually."
You do the Everybody do the meme, okay? Andrew Wilson, I consent.
Rachel Wilson, I consent. Tilly screeching in THE CORNER, "I
DON'T."
Isn't there somebody you forgot to ask? Didn't she forget to
ask Tilly?
Didn't she forget to ask Tilly if she could say if she was okay
with it? She does not consent. Have you thought about that? Wilsons,
have you thought about it?
Individuals are free to hold whatever personal beliefs they wish
about relationships or marriage.
Between this and one other clip I've seen of Tilly, I think she's
just simply not talented enough to do better. Um No, I think
you're wrong.
I Dude, she gets the British accent buff, which is so [__]
up. She just She sounds compelling because she's British. Like
she's She's okay and clearly she must be able to debate. Apparently
she debated Charlie Kirk or
But like being obstinate and British just gets you like 99% of
the way there. And then she's attractive on top of that, okay?
So, I don't know. I I feel like she's probably going to be fine.
I feel like she's probably going to make the the content creator
thing work.
I'm just I'm telling you, I'm pretty sure it's that way. I Rachel
consent, but those beliefs do not redefine a reasonable person's
interpretation
of your statements.
They do not redefine the law.
They do not shield you from people like
And for this, Andrew, I am sorry.
Nothing further.
Dude, this is I feel like it's funny cuz she looks like she sounds
like uh what do you call like she sounds like posh. She sounds
like an like a a rich British woman or whatever, right? To me,
that's how it sounds.
But then you look at the setup and it's like that all of the
technology on the screen that you could have any indication of
is like $80 put together
including her stool, her table, her mic, her lamp.
It's like bro, what the is it's not a chair, it's a stool. It's
obviously like a stool or something, right?
There's like nothing here that's set up. It's like there's nothing
it's crazy. It's like the lowest budget anything. Nothing further.
Lowest lowest budget of
I'm initiating a campaign to make public statements made by a
person in the in an intimate relationship that would constitute
evidence of coercive or controlling behavior evidence of an aggravated
form of the existing offense.
Okay, so you think it's appropriate? Okay, here's a Here's something.
Let's say hypothetically somebody had talked about like killing
me publicly on a stream, on Twitter, something like this, right?
Are you fine to call them a murderer
Does that make sense? Are you legally totally good to call them
a murderer?
Well, actually I assume you you've described the behavior that
you'd like to do that would be murder. I guess technically in
this case No, no, no, that's not accurate. That's not accurate.
No, no, no, no, no, no, that's not accurate cuz it would have
to be you would describe murdering somebody.
I can see how that could be weird. Maybe that's a good uh thought
exercise is like basically if somebody went into like excruciating
detail about how they killed somebody, would would you call them
a murderer a murderer and be fine being like
would you call them a murderer and be fine like calling them
a murderer?
Maybe if you make the argument that way, that sounds less bad,
right?
But then unfortunately murder then gets into and maybe this explains
why she brought this up, but murder then gets into essentially
like you can't really consent to being murdered, you know? There's
a limit. There's a limit.